[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
♪ Пасла коні по лану, ой і по діброві, ♪
[Полісся
Куповате]
♪ попросились ночувати солдати до вдови. ♪
♪ Ой, вдова-вдова, дай же коням сіна, ♪
♪ солдатики-голубці, я ще ж не косила. ♪
♪ Вісімнадцята зима і гарую я сама. ♪
[Ганна Заворотня
Самоселка]
Отакі пісні тут у нас, про себе.
[сміється]
Мороз же добрий був.
Зачинимо колодязь,
бо буває, що кіт стрибає [туди].
Коли вибухнуло, аварія сталася,
ми працювали тут шість днів.
Ми не знали: були на паях,
кілометра за три [від АЕС].
Ми садимо картоплю, йде голова сільради.
Він сказав: «Вибухнула атомна, збирайтеся,
будете звечора звозити поросят».
Звечора звозити поросят, каже.
Ми пішли готуватися звозити їх на базу.
«А корів будете завтра везти».
Корів на завтра позвозили,
а тут уже паски у печі, сметана, молоко.
Плачемо. Ніхто не знає, куди везуть.
Приїхали в Макарівський район, в село Копилів.
Виходить депутат, а у них три хати.
Так вона й каже: «Нехай ми з бабою будем тут,
а невістка і син — будуть там уже».
Це клуб був, бібліотека.
Бібліотека.
Клуб був.
Я тут не жила, я жила далеко.
Оце клуб був, а то бібліотека.
Ось там.
Тридцять років, як розвалини.
Літо побули у Копилові, приїхали додому.
А картопля в нас була, посадили до аварії.
Так у нас і картопля була, і все було.
Та й так ми і залишились.
Морква, капуста, огірки —
отаке садимо.
А посадиш кукурудзу — свині з’їдять.
Інколи і ночуємо там.
А чоловік мій був такий:
то лося вб’є, то таке щось.
Тепер вже його нема,
то вже і свині тут будуть, і всі.
Могла б в інше місце переїхати.
Але батьківщина.
Батьківщина незамінна людині,
і матір так само.
Плигай, бабо.
Бідна земля.
Тут уже сухенька.
Хай трошки намокне.
Лось тут ходив.
Лось такий великий, як корова.
А оно часник,
часничок,
а оно щавель накопала.
А то будуть огірки, а то цибуля сходить попри мороз.
Я її не бачу, тієї радіації.
Була радіація у 1933 році, як мене мати народила.
Двох прийняла нас, а їжі не було, ото радіація!
А як вона і є, так у мене зубів нема,
я не вкушу [її].
Трошки поллю його, бо якесь сухе,
а тоді прийду ввечері —
закрию, бо будуть морози.
Ті, хто жили до аварії тут,
залишилися працювати.
Приїхав жити у своєму будинку —
це назвали самоселами.
[Полісся
Чорнобиль]
Вулиця Гагаріна.
Це я восени з собаками гуляю,
ходжу цими шляхами.
[Євген Маркевич
Самосел, колишній вчитель праці]
А тут горіхи ростуть.
Я набираю горіхи і приношу сюди.
Тут розбиваю їх.
Бачиш, скільки?
Для синиць. А синиці тут уже їдять.
Кухня, така дорожня кухня.
Я прихистив їх у себе вдома на зиму.
Зібрав мішок горіхів на зиму для них.
І кормлю їх.
Коли почали будувати станцію,
одразу стало краще з роботою.
Люди одразу могли знайти
гарно оплачувану роботу.
Потім почали будувати багатоповерхівки,
заселяти [туди] людей.
Потім збудували дорогу.
У мене була прекрасна майстерня
у нашій школі.
Школа була новенька,
проіснувала рівно десять років.
Цей будинок на рік старший від мого.
Тут жили друзі — три брата.
Прізвище Лєрмонтов.
Хороше прізвище, правда?
Юра назвав свого сина Михайлом.
Я кажу: «Юрко, а ти не будеш соромитися,
що твій син — Михайло Юрієвич,
а таланту не має?»
[сміється]
Ну гаразд, гаразд.
Такі-то справи.
Ось тут впало дерево,
пробило дах, і все.
Хата пропала, немає більше хати.
Ну то я бачив, що там десь полум'я і дим,
полум'я не видно було, а дим йшов.
Ніхто не надавав великого значення тому,
що це може бути епохальна пожежа.
На увесь світ.
Я розумів, що рано чи пізно
доведеться їхати звідси.
А ще — до Першого травня готуватися.
Коротше кажучи, сиджу я,
збираюся, мотоцикл заводжу.
Думаю собі: «А як же я житиму?
Де я працюватиму? Чим я займатимуся?
Я ж нікуди не їду, мені ж немає куди їхати.
Я їду в білий світ, як копійка».
Я поклав одяг,
склав інструменти,
речі осінні — це ж осінь буде.
Це ж і зима колись буде.
А залишиш тут [речі], то потім і не повернешся.
Не впустять.
І собак треба вивозити, цуценят своїх.
Мисливські, цінна порода.
Якраз дивлюся, приходять
два міліціонери до мого порогу
і в гучномовець [кричать]: «Господарю!»
Я визираю: «Що таке?»
А вони далі: «Господарю!»
Що таке, питаю.
«Ви збираєтесь виїжджати?»
Так, збираюся.
«Дивіться, через пів години повернемося.
Якщо ви не виїдете, ми вас [посадимо]
в машину і так вивеземо до КПП "Дитятко"».
Я кажу: «Їду-їду».
Усіх дітей наших зібрали з чорнобильських шкіл.
У нас була російськомовна і україномовна школи.
Всіх на вокзал.
У вагони. Відвезли в Татарбунари.
Одеська область.
Там у дитячому таборі залишили дітей,
деякі вчителі з ними залишилися як вихователі.
Повернулись і почали думати, як жити далі.
Треба ж подивитись на хату, на школу.
Розумієте, усе це ще було наше,
ми ще ніби нічого не втратили.
До нас не дійшло, що це назавжди вже.
Тоді таке відчуття вже потроху було.
Дивіться, який будинок зберігся.
От хоче жінка сюди приїхати жити.
а її не пускають —
їй не дають статус самосела.
Вона приїде по гостьовій візі до когось,
поприбирає тут, почистить, покосить траву.
Кілька днів — і поїхала.
А будинок стоїть та й чекає на своїх господарів.
Я дуже хотів у Чорнобиль повернутися.
Я навіть не уявляв собі.
Москвичі приїжджали і казали:
«Давай ми тебе в Москву заберемо».
Кажу: «Не треба мені ані в Москву, ані в Київ.
Я хочу в Чорнобилі працювати».
Так і сталося — пропрацював тут 20 років.
Як ви вважаєте, чи можна жити в Чорнобилі?
Звісно, можна. Ми ж тут прожили 30 років.
Люди ж тут прожили? Прожили.
Харчувалися зі свого городу:
їли свої огірки і помідори.
Цибуля, картопля — все, як в селі.
Повітря гарне.
Не похворіли? Не похворіли.
Я більше ніде не хочу жити.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Лесик Якимчук]
[Продюсерка
Наталка Панченко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Музика
Endless Melanchholy]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]